nearly 80 1 billion dollars the latest
data from the Department of Justice
shows this was the amazing cost to keep
this many people six point nine million
in prison in jail on parole and on
probation in 2012 and taxpayers like you
foot that bill now on average that's
about two hundred fifty seven dollars
from each person each year based on a
population of 315 million people now if
you paid taxes for the next 50 years
that's as easily more than twelve
thousand dollars not yet accounting for
inflation and here's another big number
I want to show you thirty-one thousand
two hundred eighty six dollars this is
the average cost to keep one person in
prison each year that's according to the
independent nonprofit vera institute for
justice in washington DC now break it
down by state and we find a wide range
the cheapest was in Kentucky at fourteen
thousand six hundred dollars Texas
wasn't that far behind at twenty-one
thousand per inmate but on the west
coast
a California inmate cost forty seven
thousand dollars and the most expensive
well that's right here in New York at
sixty thousand and some of the reasons
for lower state costs include
overcrowding basically more inmates mean
lower costs per person and higher prison
rates for minor offenders they don't
need as many staff to watch them and all
that relates to the biggest piece of the
cost pie staff health care pensions and
insurance more than 4.2 billion dollars
according to Veera I'll leave you with
one last stat the United States puts
more people in prison than any other
country in the developed world seven
hundred seven people per 100,000
according to the National Research
Council that's followed by Russia
Ukraine Poland and Turkey why exactly is
America an incarceration nation that
raises a question for next time